[Music]
Jennifer Aniston is playing boomer
patrol my life seems so much more
dramatic and interesting than it is the
former friend star stuns on the cover of
install September issue where she opens
up to her good friend and wife of Jimmy
Kimmel Molly McNerney in her first major
interview since splitting from justin
theroux jen addresses all the
speculations surrounding her split and
so much more
telling the mad quote the misconceptions
are Jim can't keep a man and jinn
refuses to have a baby because she's
selfish and committed to her career or
that I'm sad and heartbroken
relationships happen and they happen for
a reason and they're not necessarily
meant to go on forever the 49 year old
actually seems unfazed by the made-up
stories adding I'm not heartbroken and
second those are reckless assumptions
they don't know what I've been through
medically or emotionally when it comes
to that question about starting her own
family Jin admits there's too much
pressure on women to be mothers quote
and if they are not then they're deemed
damaged goods
maybe my purpose on this planet isn't to
procreate and while the award-winning
actress has considered leaving Hollywood
for good Jen says she isn't done yet
quote I think I'll always want to keep
acting I know that I can do this until
they put me in a home
[Music]
[Applause]